to all my fellow type A perfectionists who
have obsessed over school work your body
and food this one is for you hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's [Music]
Kitchen today we're going to be getting a
little bit personal and talking about how
my perfectionist traits may or may not have played
into a disordered a quick disclaimer here that I'm
not a psychologist but I did have a chat with my
sister who is a psychologist but I'll mainly be
discussing this from personal experience and from
the research on disordered eating there are also
a lot of different schools of thought on chronic
dieting and disordered eating aty and we're just
going to be zoning into a few also if you not
already subscribed get on that today and also
check out my description to download my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook for some healthy
and meal snack ideas super quick here folks
folks I really want to talk about my sponsor
today homog glow so I have two kids and a dog
and yet my husband says that I'm probably the
messiest out of everyone # ADHD but this is
a conundrum for me because I like cannot work
very well when my space is feeling disorganized
and messy so hom glow is a five-star cleaning
service with super affordable prices way cheaper
than most services that we've paid for in the past
and also way cheaper than marital therapy which I
would probably need because because when the house
is approaching dumpster fire territory of disarray
we are gearing up for a massive blowout but anyway
the way it works is you go to Hom Glow's website
to choose the day and time that you're looking
for and the duration of your cleaning and you're
able to see all the available cleaners along with
their background checks photos and reviews so if
you work with someone that you really liked in
the past you can rebook that same person and
you can schedule it for that week or a month
from now if you want to rebook your cleanings
on a regular basis bis you can also sign up for
their forever clean membership which saves you
$30 per hour on future cleanings or unlimited
cleanings for $19 an hour all of which are backed
by their happiness guarantee and what I love most
of all is that 100% of the cleaning fees and tips
go directly to your cleaner so of course they're
also incentivized to do a great job yeah I just
feel like I can work so much more efficiently
and calmly in my space when I'm not staring at
a bunch of piles so if you want to stop fighting
with your partner over who made what mess and just
take a huge domestic Duty off of your plate go
to homag glow.com Abby or scan the QR code on
screen to get your first cleaning for only $9
okay so let's just kind of start out with a little
story time here my perfectionism has kind of been
like in short it's given me everything and taken
everything all at the same time it's made me push
and succeed and and it's made me quit and fail
but honestly if we're to kind of like net things
out it's probably done more harm than good
so here's like a quick little rundown of how
perfectionism has played out in my life in grade
school I danced competitively and won trophies
literally every time but I would cry myself to
sleep in anxiety about messing [Music] up then
in high school I traveled to London and New York
working with producers as professionally trained
singer but eventually my perfectionism and
performance anxiety kind of edged me out then
between high school and University I transferred
my perfectionistic Tendencies to food suffering
from a very severe case of orthorexia that very
well could have taken my life in University while
in recovery I drove myself into burnout fighting
for the highest grades in my class I'll show you
how valuable Woods can be like I cried for days
when I got an A on an assignment instead of an A+
and then as an adult struggling with infertility
and IVF I developed insomnia and an obsessive
relationship with sleep that literally might
have been the darkest days of my life and here
we are today I'm like 15 years past my academic
career in Ed recovery but the anxious urges to
like overthink and put pressure on myself to
be perfect are obviously sometimes still there
thankfully motherhood softened me and forced
me to let go of a lot of things as did a ton
of therapy and psychiatric medication so I'm very
grateful that I have access to all of that but I
know that a lot of you guys are in the thick of
it right now I know you guys can relate You Are
My People I am your people G me Cookie guy you
Cookie so let's talk about this double-edged
sword and how it's likely affected a lot of our
problematic histories with food well of course we
make a little snack so first of all perfectionism
is a character treat defined by sky high standards
and critical evaluation for yourself or others
that can be classified into three main categories
self-oriented where the individual drives
themselves into perfectionism socially prescribed
where you feel that others want you to be perfect
and other oriented where you expect perfectionism
from others now there's a couple of scales that
measure perfectionism so one is called the frost
multi-dimensional perfectionism scale and it looks
at things like doubts about actions concerns over
parental expectations High personal standards and
concern for precision and organization comment
below right now if you can relate to any of that
and obviously you know some level of perfectionism
isn't entirely bad so sometimes it can push us
to stay motivated or do really hard things or
reach super lofty goals I mean according to my
very unscientific media sources super successful
celebrities like Steve Jobs Lance Armstrong
James Cameron Emma Watson have all claimed to
be perfectionists I mean I've basically always
said that my perfectionism is great for everyone
but not not so great for me so more often than not
perfectionism becomes maladaptive and while it's
not an official mental disorder it is heavily
correlated with mental health conditions like
insomnia ocpd depression anxiety ADHD and EDS
we're going to talk a lot more about that in a hot
minute so like a lot of mental health conditions
oh now I have peanut butter matcha see mistakes
can be delicious H maybe not but like a lot of
mental health conditions basically perfectionism
in young people is on the rise with one study of
over 40,000 college students from 1989 to 2016
showing a significant linear climb Millennials
are apparently thought to be the generation with
the greatest perfectionistic Tendencies although
it's very possible that gen Zed will very quickly
outdo us once we have more updated stats and
there's a bunch of potential reasons why this
might be number one let's talk about some of
the major societal and cultural shifts that
Millennials and gen Z's have seen when compared to
our parents and grandparents so individualism has
been steadily On The Rise since the 1960s which
has likely contributed to us wanting to be better
than our peers and honestly we kind of have to
unlike our parents generation who could like
barely graduate from high school and be guaranteed
a pretty decent paying job and Home Ownership by
35 many Millennials and genes are stuck with
multiple degrees tons of student debt and
little chance of owning anything possibly in their
entire life the result is that we're basically all
burning out trying to be better stronger faster
harder than our peers and likely it's fueling our
perfectionistic Tendencies I mean if there are a
thousand A+ lwoods applying to Harvard then you
got to stand out and you're going to need a lot
more than a pink scented resume I think it gives
it a little something extra don't you think now
further perpetuated by this cultural individualism
is how we are raised so perfectionism actually
does seem to have some potential genetic factors
but it's also highly influenced by our familial
environment this is particularly evident between
mothers and daughters where one study found that
moms who were perfectionists were significantly
more likely to have perfectionist daughters but
mothers to daughters aside there's just a lot
more pressure put on kids right now like one man
analysis found that in response to Rising societal
increases in competitiveness uh individualism
economic inequality and pressure to excel in
school parents have just become increasingly more
demanding and controlling and the result may be
children who are much more self-critical and
fearful of disappointing their others themselves
or both I don't know as a parent who is obviously
also a perfectionist this kind of scares [__]
out of me like I don't want this for my kids and
then there's probably one of the most relevant
potential causes of perfectionism here the role of
social media so social media is kind of like our
generation's co-parent it's where we go to get
advice on literally everything from contouring
tips to weight loss to how to like fend off an
attacker in your apartment sometimes helpful but
also sometimes not so research suggests that
social media burnout which is a relatively
new psychological phenomenon is associated with
socially prescribed perfectionism self-oriented
negative perfectionism and metacognitive beliefs
about uncontrollability of thoughts and dangers
and yeah that makes sense like we got color
coordinated feeds curated photo dumps and
highlight reels of people's lives like when all
we're seeing is perfect perfect perfect perfect
perfect perfect it sets the bar really high and
you know body image issues are also obviously On
The Rise thanks again things like face tune and
professional ring lights and curated angles Etc
so yeah the expectations for what we're supposed
to look like has gotten really twisted literally
as you know there are people out there whose
entire job is to sell perfection even if that
takes dangerous diets and a th000 hours in the
gym and plastic surgery Etc and don't get it
twisted if you guys have seen my video on cool
sculpting you know that I'm not anti-plastic
surgery but it needs to be transparently part of
the conversation now obviously if you're here you
know that social media also drives perfection in
our diets I mean just look at a lot of the wedding
a day videos that I've reviewed we are in an echo
chamber where you know drinking five low calorie
beverages and building a 20 ingredient power bowl
every day is like presented as the norm if you are
not starting your day with like Corella sea moss
lemon water and ag1 are you really taking care
of your health which brings me to disordered
eating does do consuming this non-stop Kind of
Perfect diet content on social media cause eating
disorders so one study on over 600 women found
that the greater the Instagram use the higher the
likelihood of orthorexic Tendencies with 49% of
the sample showing symptoms 49% that's a lot so
the question is how does our perfectionism play
a role here could perfectionism be the missing
link to explain why some people can see a Creator
sharing their 72-hour fast and can just like
whoop scroll on by while another person could
see it and think yeah I better skip the next few
meals well it's probably not the only Factor but
perfectionism does significantly increase the risk
of developing an eating disorder the two are very
strongly intertwined and connected with one study
finding higher levels of perfectionism in anorexia
patients compared to the control group and this
makes sense seeing as people with EDS tend to
hyperfixate on the perfect body or the perfect
weight or the perfect diet EDS and perfectionism
are also both characterized by extreme rigidity
negative self-talk obsessive thinking and fear of
failure you know Hildy brush who is a well-known e
disorder psychiatrist once said that patients with
anorexia are every parents and every teacher's
idea of perfection I don't know about you guys
but I definitely feel seen and speaking of
parents because you probably know where I'm
going with this here seeing as we've talked so
much about alond moms on my channel and on my
platforms but there's plenty of research linking
parental especially maternal weight concerns and
dieting with negative body image poor self-esteem
disordered eating and chronic dieting in their
kids so when parents are perfectionists and
dieters and therefore are demonstrating and
celebrating ating and encouraging both of these
Tendencies and behaviors you can see how this
could create a perfect storm for an ed so if
you guys are still here you are probably a a
perfectionist and B have struggled with your
relationship with food and body or see you're
just like a super fan and for that I love you the
good news is I made these balls much bigger than
I probably should have hey that's what she said
the other good news is that recovery is always
possible bad news is that it may be harder for
us perfectionists than for others so research
suggests that perfectionist Ed patients tend
to have significantly less successful treatment
outcomes and yeah that's probably because you know
it's messy rule-breaking activities feel at odds
with all the little perfect patterns that keep us
feeling calm now if you are in the act of throws
of an Ed and need medical intervention then of of
course treatment related to Mechanical eating and
symptom Interruption would need to come first
but otherwise working with a therapy team to
address the maladaptive perfectionism may help to
reduce the chances of relapse so that was a lot of
uncomfy little truth bombs to process especially
for myself I mean I'm a perfectionist mom with an
ed history I am worried sick about my own kids
but thankfully a huge part of my journey has to
try to really discern which of these traits and
tendencies serve me and which don't I'm still in
the active process of trying to unlearn a lot of
the maladaptive moments of my perfectionism myself
but I thought I would share some of the little
strategies on the mindset shifts or things that
I've tried that have worked for me particularly
if you are struggling with your relationship
with food and you feel that your perfectionism
might be getting in the way of you finding food
Freedom so number one get help when you can so
as we've discussed perfectionism is a personality
trait it's not a mental health Disorder so it's
not something that we can necessarily just like
completely cure or abolish but mental health
therapy especially cognitive behavioral therapy
or CBT has shown some efficacy for managing
maladaptive symptoms now CBT has been a huge
part of my own mental health Journey over the
past 20 plus years and while it is a painfully
slow process I do believe it absolutely works and
if one-on-one therapy is not an option there's
also some great data on structured support groups
or school-based intervention with Elementary age
children there's also a lot of great self-help
books written by experts in the field so one
of my favorites that my sister gifted to me many
many years ago is called when perfect isn't good
enough I don't know it might be worth just like
adding that to your Amazon card now tip number
two is to embrace mistakes mess and Chaos as I
do throwing my myself into chaotic unstructured
imperfect eating was actually the first step to
my Ed recovery and it definitely worked but then
I basically just shifted my perfectionistic
Tendencies onto something else which at the
time was school and it wasn't until I had kids
and things got really really chaotic and messy
that I was able to actually let go and see
true flexibility improvements in all areas of
my life as with a lot of treatments for mental
health disorders like insomnia OCD uh anxiety
and E disorders overcoming a lot of maladaptive
perfectionism for me came down to exposure so one
of the activities that I do with myself but also
with my kids is like purposefully making mistakes
so I'll color Outside the Lines or I will send
like a rushed email with typos in it and not give
a I will bake or make selling without a recipe
as I did I mean this ended up way stickier than
it probably should have but guess what it's
going to be all right the important thing
here is to gather evidence that these small little
errors or mistakes they don't result in anything
catastrophic I still have a job I still have a
family I still have a roof over my head my kids
are healthy and alive and happy Etc and it's scary
to take those little leaps of Faith especially
for us perfectionists but challenging those innate
fears is a really really important part of letting
go so tip three is to recognize that moris not
necessarily always better you know perfectionism
can often drive us to set the goal post higher
and higher which basically leaves us feeling
like we've always failed we're never good enough
we're never going to reach our goal and this is
definitely an area where perfectionism and eating
disorders intersect it definitely was for me so
what started out as me making some moderate diet
changes like ordering salad with my burger instead
of fries quickly evolve to me cutting out all
sugar all fats and all carbs same with folks with
restrictive EDS like anorexia it might start off
as a quest to lose a few pounds but the goal post
quickly becomes overtaken by this assumption that
if some is good more is better until obviously
it's not now one thing that's been helpful for me
is to write down all the little tiny goals in my
day even the seemingly menial tasks so that I can
kind of like stay in the now and then each time I
check one of them off I get this little sense of
satisfaction and a hit of dopamine so I don't have
that drive and need to push it harder or faster
or further and then ultimately burn out or take
it to a dangerous extreme seeing those little mini
successes is also a good reminder to myself when
I'm being hypercritical that I have done a lot of
great things which really helps to downplay the
voice telling me that it's not enough hold that
thought I got to wash my hands this is as long
as I can tolerate this and tip four and probably
the most important for a lot of you guys who are
watching is to take take a social media break if
you struggle with social comparison I want you to
take this one thing away today social media is not
real life it's heavily cured to help the Creator
position themselves as in some way Superior to you
healthier diet hotter body higher level knowledge
though I would say I've seen a lot of creators
where I would question that one but anyways yeah
even though I don't personally feel triggered
by a lot of other people's bodies online I know
that social media is not good for my mental health
mainly because my type A tendencies in this season
of my life are largely related to my role as a
mom and I think I've said this before in other
videos but I've watched a lot of wedding a day
videos and sometimes I'm like holy am I the only
one that's not making these elaborate healthy
meals from scratch every single day for my kids
three times a day and this is a work in progress
obviously but I've actively chosen to try to be
more kind to myself and like I said like celebrate
the little wins like my kids don't think I'm any
less of a mom because we eat rotisserie chicken
instead of me like schlepping out my Ina Garden
book I know I'm an amazing mom I know I'm a great
wife and what I lack in domestic cleaning skills
I make up for with some food that my family will
sometimes at least eat that's a win right so yeah
sometimes you just got to look at yourself
in the mirror and say [__] you do a good
job I mean that's what I do anyway but on that
note I hope this was helpful for those of you
who are struggling with perfectionism and your
relationship with food if you have any advice
to share please leave it in the comments I'm sure
all of us can learn from one another and that's
all that I have for you guys today if you liked it
be sure to give it a thumbs up and don't forget to
get your hands on my Hunger crushing combo ebook
and I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
yeah